[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's that
no grandma just cilantro that's all I
need
no no just one pound of it thank you so
much hey welcome to week two of
GameSpot's play for all we are off to a
little bit of a rocky start
little shaky but it's great it's great
it's going great
uh happy Monday happy happy everyone we
are doing some fun stuff today what are
we doing well we're gonna have some
gaming trivia
I have spent maybe the upwards of the
last 24 hours trying to figure out how
to handle and lead this gaming trivia
fiasco but my name is Rob handler I'm
joined with Jake Decker tomorrow Zane
hey Kelly plaguey hello Lucy James I am
and Michael I am whoa and we are playing
some gaming trivia and we're also doing
this for the effort for charity this is
a charity stream so at any point we'll
be asking you guys to you know do your
part and if you're able to donate to
black lives matter or I believe it's
just like Cova Direct Relief is that
correct that is correct we are doing
both the first of all I just want to say
Rob you're looking very sharp today the
outfit thank you looking like a quiz
master and I think the people will
appreciate that greatly you can see the
two links to donate at the bottom of
your screens there's bit though l-wire
force SGS - BLM and then the same link
with GS - co feed both charities going
straight straight to those charities
nothing for us one black lives matter
and the other one covert relief efforts
in partnership with Direct Relief
absolutely yeah and we'll be going
throughout this stream reminding you
guys with that
what's the gist what are we actually
doing today all right guys I'm GameSpot
show
that's a fine gamespot show it's a
trivia show I'm hosting my name is Rob
Han Lauri whoa what's what's on the
plate today well I have a couple of
things initially planned one was gonna
be a like you know named a year for e3s
most memorable moments mmm maybe we'll
do that I have a bonus round on name the
famous popular gate or a game art maybe
we'll get to that as well but for the
sake of efficiency and effectiveness
what I'm gonna be doing right now is
it's gonna be called name that game
music and/or game ambience noise okay
that's all I have that's very specific
it's and yet not specific at all after
all yeah so I have 50 game noises 5055
zero lined up yesterday asked for damn
sure
sorry I can see comments on YouTube I
can see comments on twitch I'm gonna be
the only ones looking at these this is a
singular win it all type of trivia so
there's no teams here so you know free
free-for-all I will be looking at chat
if chat or sorry if any of the
contestants here can't name the game or
ambience music track whatever it is I'm
gonna be asking chat and they can help
identify it one question one question
yeah how do we how do we buzz in we like
tap our mics you say your name oh yeah
Michael oh yeah
I was gonna say do you mean sound
effects are you talking about sound
effects Valley I'm talking about
environment noise ambience ambience
I'm gonna keep saying and beyond so I
think that's a way better word
so we fit sometimes I just listen to the
ambient sound effects from the Nostromo
and alien just as like background noise
so I appreciate this
this dude started I started I started
because I remember I got 50 of these
some of them are gonna be easy summary
real hard so well the the pacing of this
is why I'm snorting is because I think
it's gonna be very unpredictable okay I
have to get away from these keychain
notifications on this laptop while
you're doing that we've got to a few
donations that we didn't cover last week
and we've got anonymous a person not the
group donated $50 anonymous a person not
the group donated $40 Michael rougeau
donate $150 very like we didn't we
didn't successfully like go a to
anonymous says yeah says we are legion
expect us and expect this $40 I made
that I made up thanks all right we about
ready to go let's all I'm right in it
okay and let's play the theme song
[Music]
not we're not guessing this right I
wanted to guess it I don't know Super
Mario Sunshine if you say your name
that's I did I've said it that's a good
test round there yeah say your name
that's the only way somebody can name
say my name okay I'm gonna get real
strict uh let's start off the first one
here just give me a second
you preload it okay here we go
so this is oh [ __ ] I don't have a
document for taking your guys's scores
one second
Wow
dude I'm nervous I like my but I got I
got that but clinch going on right now
we play boys watch we played over to the
day again someone called B sweat ah yeah
you could hear him squeaking around the
map no relax I'll forget donate to
plasma and coded relief efforts okay
here we go
no and people Machat that was super
mario world that is a game I've been
replaying recently and that's when you
robbed the amateur is what I was seeing
in the chat that makes sense you should
put chat down chat should also be
competing we're gonna lose some real
gamers out there yeah good point
but that was from super mario world a
hell of a game that's when you have
those extra lives bonus levels and you
have to like try to guess one out of
three you guys know what's up okay here
we go this is it I'm just gonna start it
[Music]
it's Mass Effect I think it was Lucy I
heard Lucy boos first alright
there's no that was a delay there's a
delay
say your name real loud see it's them if
you already won I know but it's the it's
the map same thing yeah you don't get
extra points actually it's the galaxy
map theme thank you and you don't get
any points - okay behind mr. I missed
that track man so many feelings all
right okay I'm gonna go cry now
man I'm sad aspect all right you guys
ready for the next one here we go
check are you ready it's gonna be a
delayed okay here we go
next track Michael Wade [ __ ] I didn't
let it play out long enough okay so I
don't think I'm gonna do I pause you
should pause it started started playing
more and I realized that the answer I
was gonna give was gonna be wrong so I
am going to relinquish myself from that
round yeah you only get one guess right
yeah all right
[Music]
wait I know this
[Music]
come on time time time time time say my
name what's going I'm sorry yes go the
Zelda is it well I don't think you have
to say what it's from right you just
need to say the game there have been a
hell of a lot of Zelda's out there yeah
what is it
Ocarina yes Wow I think so that sews
chat so here's the thing now just now
now the game has changed cuz Evan in the
chat actually was the first to say
something that is important gets it if
we don't get it yeah that's fair okay
that's good sorry Chan I think chat chat
would win anyway yeah yeah okay fair
fair at the same time chat is the safety
net chat wins if we suck like that's
just the you nobody wins so that was the
ice cavern and no rain at these points
okay this is going really well I'm just
laughing because I've been at I've been
dropping this [ __ ] in next one this is
ambience
brought us wind was that it this is just
an hour of ambience Rob we doing okay
how many games have wind okay is that
ten yes there's a genuinely a delay
between when I say and when you react no
I enjoy to know dick Hale oh my god I
was gonna say halo 1 because it sounds
like the level on the mountain where you
there's I did a whole speedrunning thing
to get that achievement in the think
knows like what games does Rob like Rob
well trust me trust me it won't give us
the whole it'll get better
oh it's just like interior noise I told
you it was a mixed bag alright okay so
that's one for Jake oh yeah nice one who
knows Rob the best in in honor of Jake's
win there please remember to donate
nineteen relief okay it's gonna get
better trust me okay those are the the
curve balls here's what here's one now
now this is another Beyonc right try to
identify it
you see Jake
eldest girls v skyrim that was Lucy and
yeah it was the thing is because I want
to yell the answer but then I have to
like take it from a Mac in my head to my
ass in my name
that's why I said [ __ ] okay oh good [ __ ]
how are y'all doing
I mean can you guys hear it Greg in the
background also recording we have cool
friends okay I can and I'm like oh okay
I got I got a hit mute beforehand it
[ __ ] yeah no Michael Michael Michael
Michael okay do you want to go yes okay
what pokemon blue or red jumping the gun
here because i this is 10 don't kick on
country or dead [ __ ] that was a pokemon
center for a second I'm gonna keep
playing it God that was the timecode on
the YouTube video still says 0-0 just
very impressive
I'm keep playing oh it goes out to my
boyfriend Junko
for the drop wait for the drop
there it comes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's fine that was 24 seconds I think
30 seconds is the window right
[Music]
okay I'm gonna recap on scores here Lucy
two points Tam two points Jake one point
cally goose a Michael goose a so far
damn whose egg who sake yeah I part of
that goose egg
okay let's do one more and then and then
maybe a little bit of a break no we're
only at five geez I'm 50 of these I got
let's go to 10 okay next up I believe
this is an ambiance okay listen
Jake
on hearing Bioshock that is correct
man I couldn't hear it oh my god
oh we we heard well I I have put this
really perfective trivia show together
can I just say we've upset blessing with
the undetailed Pokemon don't you don't
forget to donate please open the bottom
of the screen we'd really appreciate if
you support our causes and help us get
past your button fear fear all Finch is
calling me an amateur and that's messed
up that is that's Mustafar I'm an
amateur Emperor prepared I don't know
the names of other gameshow hosts in
America drew Carey Wayne Brady
Wayne Brady Rob handler II the great
Regis Philbin
in that order the greats oh who does
Jeopardy Alex Trebek Alex Trebek Alexis
it's Alec Trebek right is it it might be
out it's Alec Baldwin cancelled Pat
Sajak wheel of fortune he says we were
fortunate we all Dana White yeah yeah
yeah okay everyone I got our next one
ready and lined up now this is another
ambiance so do your best to identify it
[Music]
Lucy is it something weird like gta5 you
can't say is it something weird is it
like is it gta5 No
this better not be no another time Zelda
[ __ ] goddamn The Witcher 3 no my god
damn so I knew this power would go to
his head
[Music]
Jake portal 2 no okay Michael yes
[Music]
Twilight Princess all of us it goes over
to chat figures out David donated $5
thank you david rankin
thank you is it just outdoors wasn't
your relaxing background music your
phone out of a window and just hit
record this is I'm playing it off of
youtube this is the solution we found
out today
this is outside and people were saying
Zelda but no Mario 64 outside of the
castle here it's actually pretty good
yeah yeah I guess we're not gamers man
down you know that I haven't played
Mario 64 that's why it is really leaning
into the fiendish no of this okay you
said that like three questions ago it's
roasting on me lag not on livestream
we're on a seven here they get better
here's what it is the first the first 10
or 12 are probably very personal and
then it gets into stuff you could
shuffle them anyway go on Google Doc
okay here we go here we go next up
actually I'm gonna put myself in here as
just someone who got a point
Rob got one for that last one oh because
neither I saw the check on it okay okay
okay
next up wow this is another ambiance
[Music]
Michael control yeah
no man's car no Lucy right Dead
Redemption No
[Music]
do you want me to skip it or skip around
sorry like into the video to the audio
oh I know what it is
damn it I'm gonna skip one more time
[Music]
fallout 4 I'm gonna give it to them I
was thinking that was uh people said
fallout 3 follow four same difference
pull out was it who got it first follow
when I quit a column out while you find
them
Matt Hawking donate $10 towards him
there is a delay and I'm upset
Hawking donated $10 towards kovat relief
and said put Joe Biden in BioShock still
still man still man eff donated $50 with
no comment and then Mariana Whitney
Whitney donated 10 out of 10 trivia
would watch again is is chat at one or
two that are at one right no I think I
got that one right Whitney was so
donated to black lives matters and it
$25 there so thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you guys alright next up
i'm i'm so glad that DS are lasting okay
here we go
[Music]
okay what I know I'm happen Lucy Lucy go
destiny no damn it
it's like mad loud okay it's cloud
[Music]
I knew Eric so Eric knows it he doesn't
play games so what tazed not a gamer so
what could he possibly be done yeah yeah
one or two Diablo - yeah
it's either like a destiny I'm not gonna
lie that's only good because Callie and
I got dubs-y oh I'm sorry
Michael's face oh my god don't get me
started
oh they'll be for next week trivia just
a for work scream hey nothing wrong with
Miku
bro that's is nothing wrong with Miku
there's something wrong you listening to
me that's a while whoa whoa whoa it's 30
on a stream kids are watching man relax
are you looking at chat Michael y'all
ready for this yeah don't look at me I
have zero points maybe I should start
looking at it here we go I know this why
does it sound so I feel like I've heard
this in my childhood
[Music]
Pam I have to do a process of
elimination again is it final fantasy
hey it's a front of fancy eh I mean I
guess this is no so no it's not we want
to get the funnel fun suit it is a Final
Fantasy Wow
Michael Bay 9 Sam is shaking his head
how do we go about this
I'm oh you gotta get the right game you
gotta get the right game can we tam can
you agree you gotta get the right game
can we stand you were so fist can we hey
it's a consensus here Kali's on the
board never play the game please donate
plasma or kovat relief to soothe my
seething anger in this moment I'm so
disappointed in me oh I'm not I'm not
managed you play to win the game props
to you we've named every single one of
them except for the right six goes like
I do not remember a Rob can you tell me
what part of Final Fantasy seven that's
from because it's gonna drive me nuts
I have never I cannot remember B I'm
buried in the snow is the title of it
[Music]
for the snowboarding sequence Adam yeah
maybe yeah I can't wait to go
snowboarding and remake good [ __ ] though
tam I really am
enjoying people's reactions to some of
these thugs because some of them are
gonna be nostalgic but yeah your your
tap your tapping into those memories
anyways uh let's uh a little quick
little break do we want to go over some
donations do we have no let's just keep
let's keep it rolling I was just kidding
I was just kidding Wow okay here we go
next one up
[Music]
Michael pilot wings oh no come on yes
sir oh no oh that was my other answer's
no Erik you're not playing a Mario Kart
which one oh yes II the rule that's
exactly it
oh that is the ending screen when you Oh
God that's pretty good my guy didn't
even know that Mario 64 was the title
that's why I was David shield has done a
David shields has donated $100 to black
lives matter thank you oh good [ __ ] man
thank you okay good luck on this one oh
[ __ ]
that's brightness I hate this touchpad
okay
[Music]
this is this music or ambience oh this
music that's coming from the Michael FTL
No yeah it's too loud
[Music]
keep going keep going it's tickling my
brain it's tickling my ears don't think
about me anymore cuz a lot of these or
not say no more found
[Music]
I know this and say it y'all can see I
can i I'll take a guess
Jake is outer wilds no play play some
more please jazz god
[Music]
I'm gonna take a guess I'm gonna take a
guess but is it mirrors edge yes Wow
I believe that demo a lot I wasn't sure
if mirrors edge one or two it sounded
like bone feels like that's pretty good
okay before we move on to our own
Ritchie recomment a who's donated $50
towards black lives matter and also Sam
pleasure
Hancock $25 towards black lives matter
Nawaz a $25 towards black lives matter
and I think the Sam projects also donate
$25 towards Kobe relief thank you so
much everyone
remember CBS employees please submit
through CBS cares and get much why the
company yeah get the match donations
brawl okay
[Music]
okay next one up
[Music]
Jake Mario Party Oh No
I will hint to that and saying that it's
in the Mario Tennis no Michael Mario
Golf No
[Music]
- Lucy said her name Lucy said her name
really I don't know I know Glade of all
okay yes that's it is it
yeah that's it you gave us a clue then
forgot you gave us a clue I was
surprised that we go
I was surprised that she remembered I
was because there's so many games that
were said earlier so many games have
been said I'm sorry where's the pilings
are piling 6400 let's go - should I know
it let's know it yeah let Lucy guess
first like if it's pilings 150 50 here
given by like strange pilot wings 64
[Laughter]
[Music]
keep it going
TCC on has donated towards Cove Italy $5
says go 10 so he's on my team
Wow Wow well I would not play to you
okay someone someone called
Devante she's some cheese on cheese on
Chism $25 on towards blacklivesmatter
thank you so much thank you thank you
much thank you
okay I'm gonna keep rolling
[Music]
which one time on our risk it animal
crossing new leaf
no yes animal crossing GameCube no you
see yes
animal crossing wild world no Michael
animal Jake animal crossing city folk
now only one left Jake Wow
well no there's more if you count the
tall boots you know Maury are you going
Jake
I'm gonna guess one but I don't remember
the name of
[Music]
what's the what's the boardgame one
called I don't remember you know what
it's called see you chat I know what the
board game one is called I don't even
know if that's it cuz then there's also
okay well the only one I can think of is
happy home designer Oh which one does it
rest a while Tarrytown oh my god I led
us astray you did it really I thought it
was the Gamecube Animal Crossing cuz I
was like this doesn't sound exactly
right maybe my memories your own well
you know what's funny is I was I was
looking at Animal Crossing songs and
well at least for New Horizons it was
like these are so [ __ ] obvious like
especially magic everyone is playing
them and it's funny to hear you guys
flock to cuz it well I agree with you
that sounds so much like Animal Crossing
that song Jake the board game one is
called a meebo festival Jenna first chat
gets that one so they're at three
Wow Chad is killing it are guys winning
so far Lucy for Tam for Jake to Cali one
Michaels zero you'll get there trust me
you'll get there hook me up man I got
one the host is beating me at this game
keep it rolling keep it comin peach
that's what peach was say okay
deep deep cut alright here we go this is
an ambiance
[Laughter]
Oh Jake is this half-life 2 yes oh very
good very good gosh
yeah that's Jake just played half-life 2
so like 2 months ago
nice work sorry if the audio keeps
changing you know it's a it's a
shitstorm on YouTube they don't have
their same decibel range I don't know
like people can agree you know hi I'm
Joe Biden
[Laughter]
okay here we have next this is a
original soundtrack and I'll let it go
listen bastion yep all this takes a lot
of getting used to
Logan Logan Cunningham that's my guy
tell me why I'm leaning into here when
I'm wearing it yeah sorry it's hurt I'm
leaning into my microphones or too quiet
like I'm like getting ready to hear but
I'm being it's like when you were
growing up with that one kid who was
doing oh my lord does you read donations
donations donations big donation of $500
whoa
from the man the myth the legend
Jordan remain all right I'm gonna keep
going all right mm-hmm this is a special
this is a soundtrack here we go
[Music]
your face you get that ad-free
soundtrack it's like all these breaks
with every god alright all face cam was
first Assassin's Creed 2 yep that's good
me some more saying oh okay next up here
Oh what another big donation five
hundred dollars from our very own
another man another myth another legend
John Lee exactly why you better get that
match too boy thank you so much holy
crap dude we live in the Bay Area I
don't know how we can do that but bless
you all because we haven't been outside
in almost three months yeah
hey that stimulus check paid my rent so
no saying thank you so much
all right awesome stop guys thank you so
much alright next up here we go Jake
damn man is that Max Payne 3 no thing
does wait no I'm gonna keep going good
[Music]
you see it's so familiar yeah it's gotta
be a sad game I think you skip around
I'm Adam
yeah if you can skip a bit yeah sure hi
I'm Michael Sione
[Music]
Michael I don't know not right Dragon
Age ooh
was good enough I got it journey yes I
heard the violins at the beginning and
if I heard anything else I wouldn't have
called Max Payne but I heard that and I
was like Max Payne almost yeah almost it
was even that will flower like that game
company that's them right yeah
sorry chat ok this one should be real
tough Michael Michael I know is he crash
bandicoot 3 no [ __ ] no Jake
yes Crash Bandicoot 1 no yes Kelly you
play to win the game you got strats so
using Kelly your library so diverse ok
next up I'm annoyed at my stuff
hi I'm Mike
see let's hear this is the frame Ione I
hear him 15 times a day you know at
least hi I'm Michael Chiyo knee frame
i/o is really killing it here we go
cuphead yes okay up next that made me
dizzy
Michael cheering hi I'm Michael Sione
Jake super smash bros melee no this is
unit yes
Super Smash Brothers Brawl nope Kali yes
nope Michael smash okay wait I'm
actually I may have [ __ ] this up
Robert I think I think I'm right I think
you're good I know keep playing Oh keep
playing that's only what is Santa
[Music]
this is Smash Brothers it's it's the
only one we have in guesstimate every
song is an ultimate original what's the
original game so we've said we've said
many we've said so this is where I think
I'm like we've said we should the
original melee brawl what is what is for
Wii U smacking noise before it's just we
know it's smash bros for wii u and 3ds
that's its own title correct yes okay so
can I get that played in a woman I don't
think you did it properly so I let him
let him have it
damn really people gonna watch it you
know who didn't screw up is Brendan
Hernandez who donate $10 to I was a
great segue that time by the way mm-hmm
mm-hmm I was a really good segue [ __ ]
okay here we go sorry I'm working on two
computers so I keep forgetting which
ones doing what okay next up here we go
Oh Michael Michael Michael Michael
blessed that's for you Nick Nick Nick
that you both said your name at the same
time and cancel each other out
oh it's just like lit up over here those
no sound
oh I'm gonna cry now my town turned and
animal crossing is undertale oh okay
here comes next one Michael sue Tony
Tom Metroid Prime yes
yeah it's the radio static dududu ok
prime that's impressive that your friend
is so good bring that to switch it's in
my top 50 great ambiance soundtrack as
well too
yeah that's just good I know I keep
going ok next one up I just don't want
Michael Sione to be missing the [ __ ]
sound of silence
I'm gonna go fun cool I know I was
making sure that you knew the SONA 5
hold on I think I heard Tam but Mike we
were real close
I heard Cypress baby what's the verdict
here I feel like I hurt amps I say no
one what does Chad say just lay there on
delay that's fine
yeah I could totally do that I'll check
the track score update I'm at 12'o in
reality
Lucy's at five Tim's at eight Jake's at
flea cally is at two Michaels at one I'm
at one because I'm and twelve Tim's a
day Lucy's at five I meant three he's a
real deal we've got a donation from
Nathan I'm gonna pronounce this wrong so
apologies home kit home k h OE Mk II
don't know I tried my best for $25
towards black lives matter thank you so
much Nathan appreciate it
it's chat giving I've pointed time I'm
fine I think people are saying to him
people are saying to him I mean if we
want to wipe it we threw in a wipe off
the board I'm happy through that as well
I know I don't get it no one can get it
[Laughter]
okay I'll give it
[Music]
just move on nobody wins
if only we had just one more person
keeping score you know it's just crazy
we can't afford number do something very
important okay who's our dream I'm just
kidding just I'm reporting at home a
really cohesive gameshow I have Erik
you're gonna make me look after a little
bit okay perfect okay let's keep going
here
next up only on 24 what's great we're
good on edge that's half wait I timed
this out perfectly I rehearsed like four
four hours at like 5:00 a.m. here we go
next up time banjo kazooie No
Michael Oh Chrono Cross that's too deep
of a cut Oh Jake is it legend zelda
twilight princess no Lucy Legend of
Zelda Majora's Mask
no sounds very tropical yeah honey do it
I know you're thinking about it do it
cally oh my god
I think chat takes it Michael have you
guessed I did I did I said Chrono Cross
of all time it's like it's not like
Dragon roost Island or outside Islands
I'm like yeah Forest Haven oh I love
winwaker so much better bring it in
bring the with newport okay next up and
tam just interrupt if you have any
donations or anything like that okay all
right I think this is more of an
ambience
Lucy thank you was it me heard Lucy
first it was witches three
yes Wild Hunt damn I said my name like
slightly after you definitely your point
[Music]
now it's a an indie gem that not many
people played you can see a Geralt
statute in the background of Fayette
fans up it is I bit my tongue and this
one's coming up for Jake for those of
you don't know jake has pre played The
Witcher about a hundred thousand times
almost almost
okay next up hmm I've so many tabs going
oh this is definitely a little bit more
than ambience you see the last of us
know
[Music]
check out birds cake is it Red Dead
Redemption there were a lot of trees
swing you know yeah they didn't have the
tree swayed technology and res dead I've
gotten all my points so sorry
like straight trash at this you should
be playing some sound effects I would be
so good at this like different gunshot
sounds from different games yeah
igniting one cops - yeah that's the a K
from black ops 3 damn I'm getting
exposed as a fake game around here man
listen I got what are you telling me man
I'm I'm at the helm I would have been
screwed on every one of these well well
Robbie is picking the next one please
remember to donate to black life now you
can see the bitly link at the bottom of
the screen bot bit bottle wide Victor ly
full / GS - BLM and then Elway a false
SGS Co vid we're supporting black lives
matter and also direct relief in its
efforts to support healthcare workers
fighting ovid please donate generously
if you can't donate tweet out the link
to the stream and you can retweet
GameSpot's tweet about it just try and
spread the word and we want to try and
raise as much money as possible
I represent please donate I guess we'll
just keep
going on here keep it going baby let's
keep it going here's up next
yo DJ spin it damn time blood-borne yeah
is it oh my god
I've got branded to uphold damn you're
doing a little good right now
okay I'll recap on the score here Lucy's
at six teams at ten
Jake's at three Cali to Michael one I'm
at one chats at five okay let's keep
going here
DJ DJ's spinach spinach what's your dj
name Rob job broad s crickets
that's water let it fill this is a slow
burn Jake this is outer wilds right yes
I was I was unclear because you didn't
tell us if it was ambience or not so I
was quite I'm impressed you got it Jake
[Laughter]
I'll be so impressed here we go this one
is an ambience sounds like the same one
I [ __ ] with this I love the south shore
Oh Michael what okay this is this is new
this is gonna be a reach I have a
follow-up and it's going to be the same
game because I knew this was so stupid
that's why I kind of turned you near
okay we are real if we guess here if we
get here are we out for the follow-up no
no we get it now we didn't they
everybody knows the answer to the
follow-up so you should just skip the
follow-up if I was getting this we
agreed
to follow up yeah let me pick the follow
there's no way there's no way it's way
it's way too obscure okay here's here's
another ambiance is this the follow up
[Laughter]
you see is it that game rain no Michael
this is such a reach I risk of rain keep
playing on the closest no I don't know I
think I was on crack this morning you go
I don't know what it was no that was
metal gear solid 5 if tam can't get that
nobody can I thought I don't know I
thought they were like I was just flying
[Laughter]
[Music]
guess what I'm deducting a point from
Tan myself oh wow I'm off the board now
before he's gonna remove a point for me
sorry chat I don't know I blame warden
whoever was doing this this must be an
audio thing please remember to donate
using the links below
okay this oughta get this I get better
Michael is that uncharted - no
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
what is this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
morning skip Bless You Kenny
[Music]
[Music]
I think Chad takes this one that is Wow
oh I was gonna guess World of Warcraft
feels like now mists of pandaria god
this is another room you have to guess
which expansion I just call your own
picks clever
I guess this ambience crickets ago me
hurry yeah yeah
Tim GTA 5 yeah heard the siren is that
chop yeah dog yeah shout-out to $10 from
Thomas Brune who donate towards likewise
man thank you so much thank you thank
you okay let's keep going we're on
umm-hmm 33 33 mm-hmm here we go
oh go tonight 64 goddamn it damn whoo
good night you know do hell that is a
gamer bro
I intentionally went halfway through the
soundtrack just so it wasn't so obvious
yeah damn I don't play video games man
I'm beginning to think I don't I'm um
yeah I do anything is harrowing
all right all right next one up spin it
they seek Jake there Lucy first sorry
bud
it is the last of us oh yeah yeah I
thought I nodded I keep forgetting I
need more than just nodding yeah good
work very next job last that was
remastered oh it was remastered actually
music the same from Robert they're just
fully turned out I was trying to keep
things moving I'm sorry I will
acknowledge I will acknowledge the the
win here we go Michael Michael Michael
ah I'm gonna bring this bring it back to
my lab before FTL no [ __ ] them off
[Music]
Jake life is strange
no I just kinda sound like that portal 2
yes yes Wow I'm gonna keep using FTL
until I get it right
well your hand looked really smaller
when you did that Brad small and luri do
that same motion where you had someone
clip that when he when he paused it it
was like really small hand okay okay
we're gonna wrap up okay next up boy who
won that yes oh please remember to
donate using the links below please do
eat okay I'll do a score recap Lucy
eight team twelve Jake for Callie to
Michael one Rob music and chat at six
God don't I don't want to have small
hands there are worse things there are
worse things for sure
small years no Michael RT 1.4 Nellie
okay one point known as point
[Music]
Pam minecraft [ __ ] this [ __ ]
looking at chat comes up no leave me
alone
Rob's got a screen share directly at a
time it's rigged okay next up [ __ ] don't
give me don't give me frame skip skip
skip skip skip
I'm Michael ravioli and I like pasta you
should too
okay here we go playing yeah I don't
hear anything time I'll can see no Jake
yes Arkham Asylum yes eight to see it
absolutely hate see it
you see then it's ragin I'm not because
we have $25 from Craig Gilmore which he
clipped an incredible moment earlier i
retweeted it where I take my mug it
looks like I pass it to town because
tamping the same side of frame it looks
amazing yeah I just see y'all did it
again I saw it
do ya you stop doing that y'all even
planning things to go viral fake my
reality oh yeah they planned it it's
fake viral it's really cute
[Music]
Oh Buddhist ominous the outer worlds
that's right
oh my god you didn't even play that game
okay he did I don't know what's going on
damn what is are you in my brain the
feet in your Google Doc is this is this
is like a B what is that look when we
played the detective game man this is
just it's not fair I recognized that
motif just because I spent ages
preparing for the interview with the
developers oh that's right Oh videos I'm
gonna let this one run DJ spin it
[Music]
Oh Jake
is it a plague tale no I know what oh
wow wow wow I can't hear any more Lucy
God of War yeah mm 2018 there's a lot of
sad violin in this mix yeah it's all I
know Max Payne 3 yeah is the king of
violin
please remember to use the links below
to donate to black lives matter or Kobe
relief or both please why not both
everything can be iced if you can't
donate you can share the links tweet out
the stream so people can come in and
watch and donate as well please please
please sad violin and crickets and birds
chirping noises damn what we go and
waves crashing what's next Rob oh I
guess you could call this one good luck
there's no huh I can't hear it maybe
it's just there's not a chance
anyone what Alan Wake no Blaine now
please play it I want to hear it I can't
have a negative one oh my god what is it
I am Odin oh yeah I can't I can't tell
what's actually part of a what's like
feedback from the core overwatch it was
good Hollywood huh no no no I know what
you're planning I talked to my guy who
made this list he's my cousin okay here
we go it's probably not whoa
just kidding oh my god changed my score
to negative one Oh guys this is yes this
is a this is a good Michael hey Michael
I think Michael innit
that's that's Super Mario World that's
exactly right yeah looks like wait we
had Mari we're on the beginning but that
didn't count because that was that was
the theme song yes
so AHA - was good I'm catching up hell
yeah
okay here we go
on the next one this is gonna be a good
one oh sorry there's an ad it's for
health care it's a family walking
through the oh no you know it's for
claritin itching burning redness what no
no no no enough likes yeah okay here we
go Michael braids no damn Kelly's yeah I
will say this is a franchise so this
could be anyone
[Music]
Dragon Quest no I can skip around I will
do any I will take any name it doesn't
have to be
[Music]
no Kelly that's the Sims that's the same
bass that's one like the sims 4 though
what the hell man that is not Sims
classic yay I practiced I said it's from
the franchise that's good that's good ok
[Laughter]
[Music]
no Lucy Street Fighter I will give you a
yellow flag on that one you're on close
watch Missy did a great episode of
remember when about 3 5 2 which is why I
knew it because I had to QA that video a
lot so and also time was in it it was
great it's bad
ok 44 oh wow we're almost done Wow
[Music]
more sad violence halo 3 no Michael
yes halo ODST damn alright
everyone knows what to do yes Halo Reach
no planet please
[Music]
Jake say hallo - it is hallo - dammit I
know this is how I got most of my points
a little Rob dog curveball with the
ambience something else but ok bees
don't know no I'm just gonna say please
donate to charity instead of thinking
about what that curveball is oh yeah
sure sure thank you - Samuel Pauly you
know who donated $25 towards black lives
matter who don't know you download it we
downloaded $25 for black lives matter
much appreciated
you wouldn't download a donation stop
all the download thank you
[Laughter]
here anything you want make I'll skip it
I thought it was good because you could
hear a faint you could hear a faint
sound effect of something in it but I
have it I have a second-tier option here
[Music]
there's an evil for yep
[Music]
lightning Fox than that yeah that was
really fast just finished playing the
entire franchise in the ether what was
the answer again sorry I can put over as
any von Rosen uniform that's what's up
okay here we go
DJ spin it you got it
[Music]
sounds like something I would name Tam
Celeste
no Callie good good
call out though that's that is very
similar net go ahead Callie sorry earth
no I wasn't saying that is close Michael
Drury it's real subtle
Jake I don't think this is right but no
man's sky now do you want me to skip
around in this having guests
bet it's FTL watch hey [ __ ] man
oh my god oh wait Super Mario RPG
[Music]
Odyssey Oh pace I actually play that one
yeah yeah check it son
congrats chat Chad's dad Chad's got
three four or five oh let me let me out
let me recap here because we're on the
last stretch here we got one two three
four left mm-hmm and the score so far
Lucy's at ten Tam's at 14 Jake's at
seven Kelly's at three Michaels at two
Rob z800
chat is that seven so Michael and I just
shouldn't even bother how were we here -
were here to spoil everyone else from
winning yeah we're here to protect him
alright hey we're just we're just have
fun yeah we're providing we're here with
vibin for kovat relief efforts go to bit
ly for /es - Co vid or bit ly for that
she SPLM to donate to black lives matter
please donate generously 100% you know
the vibes sushi sushi she's dug into the
blinky alright
here we go spin it whoa
Oh Michael Michael Michael Michael the
Metal Gear Solid no no what oh [ __ ] it's
like it like caution or something like
mm-hmm
damn fake gamer
cake Far Cry blood dragon no Oh Lucy oh
portal no no let me I need to hear it
check out it or namely crisper I got it
don't look Oh Chris Pereira got it
whispering I gotta keep playing it
skip around yeah but if this is FTL um
be pissed
no oh oh I see why you're in for that
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah very much the intro time basics
no definitely damn perfect darkness that
is a good ass game yeah right okay we
got three left here we have another $10
donation from which she also donated to
black Ozma and covert relief from the
covert relief oh and she said thank you
for hosting such a fun and rigged trivia
both the facts you know hits it yep talk
to my agent his agent is just Rob with
his grandma computer boot up next
computer it's not letting me hyperlink
the tell Alexa oh oh you know what I
wonder if it is I wonder if it's because
I have 800,000 tabs open and it's like
dude we can't do any more tabs man let
them open I don't know I
hi it's Google Chrome you've maxed out
on tabs do you know how much RAM Google
takes the area
yo a grip you got it you got to put them
in check yeah test them out you know
here we go
oh this isn't this isn't right that's
not the right one [ __ ]
my face is hell of retro logitech Brio
for giving me jaundice in this stream I
promise you I don't look this orange
more like a soft tan brown soft tan
yeah soft tan Brown and please remember
to donate generously to the black lives
matter effort which you can see the
links for below and also a Direct Relief
every penny every cent every dollar
helps and it goes straight to black
lives matter or Direct Relief and we are
not involved in any sort of cut of it so
please donate generously retweet and
share the links to stream or share the
links to our donation links and yeah
please give what you can
well said please donate
we're just nearing the end here of our
insane audio trivia this is it here's
well this isn't really yet we have like
a couple more but this is one of them
here we go
[Music]
Lucy
final fantasy 15 no Super Mario Galaxy
[Music]
can hear the little luma in the
background that sounded like a Mughal uh
yeah I was thinking Mughal then yeah I
was gonna say if it wasn't 15 it sounded
like a little bit like 12 whatever okay
yeah you do stupid game for chicks dude
tomorrow plays video games talk about
games oh okay coming out John here we go
big Cleopatra Cleopatra coming up yeah
here we go
deejays
[Music]
[Music]
Lucy oh damn it it's over watch no one
answer real quick let me just fine
it's fine I'll credit credit safe okay
whoa we have a donation $10 from Hawking
- thank you Dan who says need a video
montage of Lucy rocking out to every
track DCCC $10 good job thank you so
much and then we have a $20 donation -
from black eyes now from our very own
goop shoe riot thank you so much good
what am I gonna see you again man
hopefully soon it's the last one
he's mewed himself I don't think he's
realized oh I know I have I was testing
you again no I was just totally testing
that was actually very intentional I
just wanted to put it on the [ __ ] better
be good okay last one this is it okay
don't get scared now
[Music]
I know what the franchise is but I'm
annoying cake is that just from the
first Super Mario no no no I just want
to answer I'm just gonna get a ball
rolling on this Super Mario Land no I
know it shown it is slack me Jake now
now are we giving up no good guess the
other games in that franchise
I'm sure chats losing their mind
[Music]
[Music]
Lucy again preface to the fact that I'm
on Mario Playa Paper Mario Super Mario
Bros 3 that's it
yeah no it's actually not we call it I
didn't have an NES or a Super Mario 2
what uh what an ending all right
well that'll have a Oh you wonder bonus
for some more minutes okay come on
minutes
yeah yeah yeah do you wanna do hey do
you want the Google Drive link that I
put them all in and all you need to do
is yeah the only thing is you don't want
to show the go on yes in the folder
would give it away okay okay there's no
there's not too many in here but this
should finish up ladies and gentlemen we
are playing trivia fiendish trivia for
in aid of raising money for black lives
matters I think you can see at the
bottom of the screen bit no ly for size
GS - BLM same link but with GS - co vid
and you can donate over to black lives
matter or Direct Relief please donate
generously there are nine minutes left
in this segment I desperately need to
pee well I wet myself live on the
Internet we'll find out soon enough
let's go another hour two points each
right dude I'm down if you sir for this
two points each sure yeah okay
all right chat does get that point ice
were so so invested in the scoring here
say in the defense of me and Michael
maybe we're just not super auditory you
know I'm not about sad violins and for
like freaking grant kirkhope something
yeah wait no yes I was waiting for don't
keep on there was there is serious
there's a serious missing piece of
Japanese music yeah very surprised that
there wasn't any Kingdom Hearts like I
was sorry what was that Jake it was a
good selection it was a
I have had a very fun time a lot of fun
the fact that I can write you know the
fact that I can get paid to do this is
lovely
well actually Tim that's up to Tim but
well I mean you get paid either way
yes I don't know we have a we have a
very fluid structure here I don't know
Rob because yours boss sometimes pays my
boss you know ice who knows
I wake up in the morning I have no idea
what's going on my life let's not worry
about hi I'm game paid let's make sure
that we are worrying about black lives
matters and Colvig 19 getting paid you
can see the donation links at the bottom
of the screen please donate generously
if you can all the money go straight to
those causes and they are worthy and
desperately in need of your support
please donate generously if you can yes
Google drive's new sharing options are
so confused anyone else I know right
okay that should be good with Google
Drive sharing options yes
okay that's exact
you
okay no the answer will come so how I
structured like one you want to do one a
first and then one B is the answer does
that make sense to A to B yeah well
let's do it before do you want to chat
yes which are its for example yes yeah
Before we jump into it we've got $25
donation from Josh Cole towards black
Lesnar and Robert Henry has done it in
$100 towards black lives matter thank
you thank you thank you Robert Henry uh
oh I thought you should handler if
that's one look imposes me no no Henry
Hill Robert Henry yeah thank you Robert
Henry what I would say to preface this
bonus round is name that box art so
what's gonna happen is we're gonna try
to show a zoomed-in select a composition
of a box art and you try to guess what
game it is and then we'll zoom out and
reveal the famous video game box art
easy enough makes sense yes let's go
let's go go do it
jump on it Chelsea Lucy oh so no this
one doesn't count cause we've seen we
know this one yeah so this is four
chances the check that's fine
I've made your screen like the main one
anyway okay so this is for check no they
already got it two points a chat yep so
that is correct that is that is ico if
you want to show you show the full one I
guess right there it is
it's the window in the box art okay
shouldn't swing in the back side the box
art next up j2a okay grand theft auto
vice city thats me two points baby let's
go okay you can just mouse you can just
like use the keyboard and use the arrow
keys oh yeah yeah that should work out
in order done yes final fence you can
yes can you see God no it's the too
small you can't see him okay cool JC Wow
he was uh that was me I'm pretty sure I
heard Jake first yeah okay I haven't
done typing these down I each got two oh
yeah you got
okay sixteen Jake's at eight okay
and this is Star Wars Knights The Old
Republic
- Michael time and it's what Michael
coats are one I'm sorry I got confused
okay so Michael is Michael hurt Sam
quake3
take quake I didn't say I thought I know
I got robbed you have to confirm I
thought I did I thought I said download
my bad yeah tam got that one J queasy
doom original Lucy was that yes or no
yes you guys can't hear me then I'm
saying yes I must be bad my bad okay
I'm saying yes out loud I'm so sorry uh
okay go next Lucy tam it was time it is
that's correct
tam it is heavy right okay one second uh
yeah go for the next one Michael yeah
half-life 1 that's right yeah half a
little if go for the next one
shake yes uh Katamari that is correct
damn J wow your this is bonus bonus
bonus rounds helping you out I think we
have two more left
go for it
Tom you see Tim left for dead
Lucy Jake oh no Lucy Lucy's next yeah
dead space that's correct
Wow okay
final round go for it who was that
was it Jake that is correct
okay I guess that's gonna do it
that got a little weird in the end but
we just hit 2:00 p.m. we made it I can't
believe it
little ties right before we go we've got
a Matt rich donated $24 swords corvid
relief set for Street Fighter 2
keep up the good work and then we got
Patrick
Leonard's Matei $25 towards black allows
Maya thank you so much everyone thank
you all for the donations
Lucy thank you should I go by ranking
yeah so from the bottom and then go up
from the bottom sure Rob negative one
that's [ __ ]
next is Kali with three Michael with
five
[Music]
check gets nine damn Lucy 12 Jake 14 and
TAM with 20 okay I did be Lucy the Box
arts that strategic suggestion of two
points per box always good do it thank
you guys so much thank you guys for
donating thank you guys for joining us
stay tuned for the rest of the week we
have tons of awesome stuff coming
Tamm Lucy you guys wanna elaborate more
on what we got in store Troy Baker we
have we're playing apex legends with
Watson and Mirage that's Justine Huxley
and what you pick Smith salmon we are
gonna have to move seven can because
nobody is gonna be right on top of it
and then we're running off the weekend
with Danny or Drive so that's just
that's just this week that's just this
week yeah things are all subject to
change as as Lucy just kind of hinted at
like initially we had you know as a
baseline we have our charity stream and
then when big announcements press
conferences if you will when they happen
we try to make it as malleable as
possible so yeah just stay tuned we have
something going on every day regardless
so yeah participate and thank everyone
thank you everyone for donating lives
matter and Coe bid first relief rectly
I'm sorry my bad first responders for
their direct relief I could see how
you'd smush room together yeah just
really trying to be concise but that
didn't work out
cool I thank you all for joining this
fun little gaming trivia that's a good
Monday good way to kick it off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]